[Music]
[Music]
hey guys the first episode of the final
season just ended
and it was spectacular before we make
breakdown on the episode 2 preview let's
first review the season 8 premiere
it's one of the strongest probably the
best opening episodes we've ever seen in
game of thrones
before the opening scene we are created
with a new intro that has some major
differences
the intro is completely changed from
winterfell to king's landing
instead of just gliding over the red
keep the new opening credits take us
inside where we see dragon's skull that
we saw in season 7.
the intro even includes the iron throne
now the ball has changed as well
with a massive hole at eastwatch this is
obviously a reference to the scene at
the end of season 7
when the night king destroyed portion of
the wall by using the undead dragon
viserion
the ice lore that spreads out from the
ball representing the night king and his
army who brings the storm and winter
goes to the lost heart
the seat of house sumber and right there
before the episode even started we knew
the last heart was doomed
the episode begins with john and dany
arriving in winterfell in a callback to
the series very first episode of the
first season
with dany and her camp standing in for
king robert and his
everyone is president other than arya
who is watching their rival among the
small folk at winner town
beside john denny in her armies of
course dragons survive as well
and sansa seems to be just as impressed
as arya's
with his family john hugs his brother
and tells him how much he's grown since
the last time he saw him
but brained his eyes cold so dreaming
between him and john turned out exactly
how he expected
unsatisfying john then introduces dany
to his family and what follows is a
tense meeting between danny and sansa
sensa does say wienerfell is yours your
grace the same line her father said to
king robert when he arrived at
winterfell
but by sansa's face expression we can
see she doesn't like any of that
after jon's reunited with his family and
has introduced dany to them bran tells
everyone they don't have time for this
the night king is coming brain also
tells dany about viserion
which she's shocked about this leads to
a huge meeting in winterfell
in the great hall most of the characters
are present but tarya is not
topics discussed on this meeting include
introducing dany the current status of
the troops and their defenses
john says they need to send ravens to
let everybody know the night king has
crossed the wall
and has his own dragon den is watching
the reaction of the northern lords which
is not very
sensible lady mormon says they named him
king in the north
and it's his job to rule it not danny
john emphasizes the importance of allies
and how they cannot win the great war
without dany
tyrion says great things about jon and
tells everybody's sister promised to
send the troops
he is confident that the lannister
troops will be coming the north is in
outrage because they cannot believe
lannister troops are coming to the north
then the tyrion's line from the trailer
comes we must fight together now or die
sense is concerned about the landscape
troops and talks with tyrion
she asks him if he really thinks cersei
is going to help them tyrion vouches for
his sister and says they're there to
help
tyrion defenser say which might add some
fuel an already popular theory about a
secret deal that those siblings
might have made during their closed door
meeting in the season 7 finale
especially sansa's reply to that i
thought you were the cleverest man i've
ever met
implying to how can tyrion be so naive
the look bran gives say might also be a
hint of tyrion's betrayal and he's seen
it but then again tyrion is known for
reading people as good as books
so does he really think cersei is going
to help them or is it a part of his plan
it's going to be interesting how
tyrion's story plays out later on in the
season
tyrion might be working with cersei
meanwhile in king's landing qyburn
informs cersei that the night king has
crossed the wall and he is the dragon
which is a great news for cersei let
them kill each other in the north
there's also a little chat between euron
and his niece ciara about the queen
euron finally arrives at king's landing
with the golden company but without the
war elephants which seems to enrage the
queen
but nevertheless has to sleep with urine
for bringing the golden company from
essos
the golden companies introduced a new
character their leader harry strickland
in case you don't know the golden
company is known for never breaking a
contract
but in the books they broke it for the
first time to side with the targaryen
so we should keep an eye on that
possible twist i also believe aerys will
be the one to turn the golem company
against cersei
colin hill teased this about his
character varys versus effective as
always
what his means and for shadows is verse
turning the golden company against
cersei and yeon
persuading them to fight for the last
regular son aegon targaryen
since after all black red a dragon is
still a dragon
we have been listening over and over
again how the golden company have never
broken a contract
that them breaking it and supporting
targaryen seems like such an obvious
twist of the final season
additionally as i already said the
golden company have already broken a
contract in the books
the reason being a targaryen also at
king's landing bronn gets offered a ton
of money to kill jaime and tyrion by
qyburn at a request of cersei
now some of you might believe braun is
actually going to do it especially with
it kind of being foreshadowed in season
7
after the lucha in battle when braun
said to jaime i'm the only one who gets
to kill you
remember braum pulled jaime from the
deaths of the water and onto the shore
after jaime's failed attempt to slay
dany and end the war
brandon told jaime that the only reason
he rescued him is so he may be the one
to ever finish
him off until he gets what he wants from
him sure it could be some for shattering
here
but what we also need to remember is
that tyrion promised braun to beat any
attempt to buy bronze loyalty by paying
double
after all brown likes the lannister
brothers much more than he likes the
queen
and in addition to that braun doesn't
really need any more money
as he said to jaime he's got plenty of
gold but all he doesn't have and eagerly
wants is the promise castle and the
highborne beauty for wife
cersei could secure him all of that but
brown is smart enough to realize cersei
cannot win this war at the end
and yes that's joffrey's crossbow cersei
wants braun to kill her brothers with
the same on tyrion used to kill their
father bronn is definitely heading north
but he will not kill any of the lane
serves nor will he try
he will reunite with jaime and tyrion at
the manor fell in the upcoming episodes
and will fight alongside jaime during
the battle for winterfell
just as i predicted the premiere also
provided a closure on theon's rescue
mission
theon rescues yara and tells her he's
going to win or fail to help jon
it was an emotional scene because yara
wanted him to come to the iron islands
with her
but realize this is something he's got
to do theon is on his redemption path
for the starks
wouldn't be surprised if he sacrifices
his life by saving sansa against the
white walkers
the john and arya reunion was cute john
started if she ever needed to use the
needle to stick someone with the pointy
end
and she applies giggling once or twice
and they also give each other an
emotional hug
this is obviously a call back to season
1 when jon and arya less saw each other
john had needle forged for arya and
instructed her to stick with the pointy
end
their union was not more emotional than
jon and sansa's because of the fact
they're all home
and they're in much better place it took
place by the weirwood tree but it was
also pretty short
pretty underwhelming reunion for all the
build up but it wasn't a bad scene
aria also seemingly knows jon is a
targaryen since she says to him don't
forget very family
and she also knows jon will step to the
heart as she tells him that
both of this she found out from her
brother brain
as expected john is now riding a dragon
just as we thought these shots of john
and danny approaching dragon ragel turn
out to be from the season 8 premiere
and here they're flying them above
winterfell and this is reaction of
various davos centurions seeing it
as i already said all these three have
already seen dragons above their heads
quite a lot of times
so the only reason they'd look at a
dragon with a bit of shock would be
seeing jon snow riding then his other
dragon regal
a dragon named after jon's father ecker
targaryen and that's exactly what it
turned out to be
although unexpectedly was pretty simple
process of dany teaching jon how to ride
one
john is kind of struggling at first but
very quickly gets the hang of it
obviously it was that simple because jon
is in fact a targaryen
and the dragons could definitely sense
that jon and dany make out after they
land
and i'm sure they did much more than
that then he also said one interesting
line
they could live here for a thousand
years and nobody would find us
could this be a foreshadowing that after
and if they win against the night king
could they perhaps decide to give up on
the armed throne and ruling altogether
and find some place far away and live
out their days peacefully
emilia clarke or dany said this in an
interview the whole show is just a
discussion of power
because the armed throne is a
representative of complete and consuming
power
and what that does to someone it's
fascinating what i have found about the
sacrifices that you make and you get out
of it as a result
ultimately if you get on the throne what
are you really getting the game of
thrones star went on to reference star
sail in a heady heading
cersei proves that you're not getting
that much you're getting a lot of
loneliness spain critiques
emilia's comments set up the stage
perfectly for john danny destroying the
armed throne
setting up a console and walking away
from all of it with their child
they said it to dennis we could live
here for a thousand years and no one
would find us dialogue in episode 1
could be a huge clue for their endgame
back to the reunions
beside reuniting with john are you also
reunited with the hound and gendry who
is preparing weapons for the great war
when arya and the count reunite there's
a hostility between them they both seem
to be acting
although when they actually wanted to
hug each other when she walks in he says
you left me there to die
and she replies saying i robbed you
first he doesn't really have a rebuttal
he stares for a bit and says something
along the line of you're a bit
aren't you and he walks away it's their
usual banter from season 3 and 4.
clegane seemed to be almost proud
apologetic for a second but then he's
back at being himself
genji and darya had a cute banter going
back and forth slightly sensual tension
with old jokes
he calls her lady which she did not like
back in season 2 and neither does she
like it now in season 8
while still gentry keeps calling her his
lady it seems like a love affair in
making
possibly hinting their future marriage
and fulfilling the promise genji's
fathers robert baratheon made to arya's
father ned stark in season 1.
remember back in the very first episode
in the winterfell crypts
robert baratheon expressed his desire
that his son should marry ned's daughter
to line their houses once and for all
robert was talking about joffrey who he
thought was his son and that's daughter
sansa
however this never happened and
therefore how stark and how's baratheon
have not been joined yet
however a huge amount of fans think that
this marriage might finally happen in
the form of robert's only son gendry
and ned's other daughter arya gendry is
also building a weapon
of arya's design for her with which
she'll fight the dead in episode 3 while
defending minerval
after that first disastrous assembly jon
has talked to sansa
she keeps telling him that his duty is
to defend north and he's not taking her
advice seriously
he keeps telling her they need allies
eventually sansa confronts jon
did you bend the knee for the north or
for love also glover starts staying home
and car starks arrive in the middle of
the episode at winterfell
speaking of dany meeting senza stark was
not her only tense meeting
as beside the lady of ennerfeld she also
met johnson's best friend simultarly
whose father and brother she burned
alive in season seven
daenerys sanjora's scene with sam in the
library was also emotional
danny and jorah finds sam to thank him
for healing jorah
sandbegg's pardon for stealing books
from citadel and his father's sword
which is when danny learns school sam
truly is
danny asks him if his father is randall
tarly and he says yes
which is when she learns sam doesn't
know yet about what she's done to his
family
archmaestrebros was going to tell sam
about his family fate in season 7
but same departed before he got a chance
now sam hears it from the one who passed
the sentence
dany confesses to executing his father
after his refusal to bend knee
sam is visibly upset but at least he is
able to go home now to visit his family
with his brother as the head of house
tarly
more bad news for sam then he says she
killed him as well
sam excuses himself and leaves the room
many argue sam will not care about it
and truth be told he did not more much
about his father but as expected he
cared about his brother
however sam is very grateful for the
information and confused in his emotions
goes to talk to brain
brain tells him they need to tell the
truth to john that will decide it's
better if sam tells him
sam goes down to the crypts to inform
jon but before revealing it he tells him
about his father and brother
sam asked jon if he would have done the
same thing john says no
but i'm not the king this leads into sam
telling him that he should in fact be
the king
and not just king in the north by the
king of the seven kingdoms
same reveals to john who he truly is and
he is in disbelief and shock
john replies by saying but then he's
still the queen to which same replies
you bend the knee for your people and
she should do the same
sam is pushing for jon to be the king
but it looks like jon still believes
dany should be a queen
let me remind you that jon did not bend
the knee because he thought dany had the
best claim
or because he needed her and her dragons
against the night king
then he promised to help the north a few
moments before jon bent the knee
meaning that he did not do it because of
her claim or because he needed her as an
ally
but because he believed in her and
therefore jon still believing danish to
remain the queen is definitely not
surprising to me
it's going to be very interesting to see
the next scene between jon and dany
is he going to tell her about this huge
reveal or keep it a secret for now
i'm also curious how their relationship
will look like in the next episodes as
well
i'm pretty sure dany got pregnant and
they will marry later on in the season
mainly because of their child i do not
think jon would allow his child to be
born out of wedlock and be a bastard
then there's a short scene in the last
card that shows us an undead net number
it was clearly a dumb decision for him
to stay in his castle
the last heart the seat of house summer
was attacked by the night king
who left behind the same old recurring
spiral symbol that we've already seen
before
tormund berry can then stumble upon the
aftermath of the white walker slaughter
at last heart while traveling south
even though this is terrifying the
iranian between old friends tormund and
dead was pretty funny
they're both sninging around the castle
in dark and suddenly run into each other
eddie elves get him his eyes are blue
tormund yells my eyes have always been
blue
and then they hug it was hilarious and
definitely matches with many reports of
the premiere being the funniest episode
of the show
the episode ends with jamie linster
arriving in winterfell he gets off his
horse and there his
brain stark a kid he pushed out a window
in the very first episode of game of
thrones
bran reunites with a man who tried to
kill him because he saw him having an
intimate relationship with his sister
obviously we don't expect from the
starks to execute jaime for this
after all jon snow and dany invited the
lannisters to come and support the
living in the wars to come
jaime agreed another displedge meaning
that no harm would jon do to him
nor would he allow anyone else to do so
starks are not the phrase
that's not their way brian stark will
likely forgive jaime
and this one will probably save bran's
life in episode 3 during the battle for
winterfell
tyrion and brienne will be proud that
jaime has honored this
dany and sansa will be a bit suspicious
about his intentions
upon finding out that cersei betrayed
him they will ask him why did he come to
win her film and his beloved sister and
lover is obviously not going to help
them
and why should they even trust him
that's when jaime's line from the
official trailer will come out
he will reply with i promise to fight
for the living and i intend to keep that
promise
can't wait for episode 2. the worst part
about the episode ghost is number to be
found
overall the first episode was great and
kind of a teaser of what's to come
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace